dozens of shots rang out at the busy
Allen Premium Outlets mall Saturday
afternoon As Shoppers sprinted to safety
the gunman seen here in dash cam video
we've Frozen fired dozens of rounds at
customers outside the stores police say
an officer who was at the mall for an
unrelated call confronted and killed the
gunman
law enforcement sources tell CBS News
the shooter was wearing body armor and
was heavily armed with an AR style rifle
with dozens of rounds of ammunition
Amber told they said she sheltered more
than 60 people inside her store during
the attack you never expect it so to be
involved in it is just another thing
that just is nothing you can explain
Steven spainhauer raced to the scene
after receiving a call from his son who
was working at one of the stores I
started counting bodies I counted seven
spainhower said he arrived before police
got to the mall and started looking for
survivors